chaque année l'éclosion de ces fleurs
jaunes nous annonce que le printemps est
enfin là mais si le retour du beau temps
réjouit à peu près tout le monde les
pissenlits eux sont loin de faire
l'unanimité voici en 5 minutes quelques
questions-réponses pour démystifier
cette plante souvent mal aimée
[Musique]
les grands champs en ville c'est
peut-être plus discutable mais dans les
champs en campagne lorsque c'est couvert
de fleur jaune je trouve ça magnifique
moi j'avais biologiste des plantes
envahissantes mais pas juste des plantes
envahissantes des plantes exotiques
envahissantes donc des plantes qui
viennent d'ailleurs autrement dit quand
tu es introduite en Amérique du Nord à
partir d'autres continents et le
pissenlit c'est la plante exotique et
envahissante par excellence
avant le 17e siècle il y avait pas de
pissali en Amérique du Nord enfin du
moins le pissenlit officiel
il est venu en Amérique du Nord avec les
premiers colons européens qui se sont
installés en Virginie en
Nouvelle-Angleterre et bien sûr dans la
vallée du Saint-Laurent
c'est une plante qui est nutritive c'est
une plante qui a des vertus médicinales
plus ou moins démontrées mais quand même
on s'en sert depuis plusieurs siècles
pour guérir certains problèmes
c'est aussi une plante qui est très
intéressante pour les insectes
pollinisateurs particulièrement au bout
du but du printemps où il y a somme
toute pas tant de plantes que ça qui
peuvent fournir du pollen et du nectar
aux insectes pas juste aux abeilles
domestiques mais aussi au Bourdon et
également aux abeilles indigènes
[Musique]
un individu va fleurir à l'âge de deux
ans va fleurir pendant une douzaine
d'années consécutives et chaque année va
produire entre 2000 les 3000 semences
alors dans un champ très avis de
pissenlit ça va représenter à peu près
dans l'école les plus extrêmes à peu
près 15 millions de fleurs par hectare
qui vont produire collectivement 140
millions de semences par hectare alors
ça fait beaucoup de semences qui vont se
disséminer par le vent et qui vont
éventuellement envahir d'autres
environnements propices à la croissance
du puissance
la racine de pissenlit les profonde a pu
atteindre parfois une trentaine de
centimètres de profondeur elle va
profondément dans le sol aller chercher
les éléments nutritifs l'eau tout ce qui
va permettre à sa place à cette plante
de survivre c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que
dans les périodes de sécheresse dans les
pelouse souvent la seule chose qui est
vert c'est le pissenlit
[Musique]
en général les pissali c'est plutôt
inoffensif en agriculture la chose c'est
un peu différente
traditionnellement le pissaliste a
jamais été une grosse mauvaise herbe si
vous prenez des manuels d'agriculture
publié au début du 20e siècle c'est même
pas dans la liste des plantes nuisibles
et pour cause parce que c'est une plante
qui se contrôle assez bien avec des
labours des labos traditionnels par
contre on fait de plus en plus une
agriculture sans labo avec ce midi
direct et là effectivement le pissenlit
émerge à l'occasion comme une plante
plus ou moins désirable qui peut
affecter quelque peu le rendement
pour le bétail c'est considéré comme un
fourrage autour de ces bonnes qualités
c'est peut-être pas nécessairement un
fourrage qui conserve très bien aussi
bien que les graminées mais il y a pas
de problème à ajouter du pissali à un
fourrage les vaches règles générales
vont même en raffoler à certaines
circonstances
le pissenlit là où il fait mal c'est
dans la pelouse pourquoi parce que la
pelouse c'est son habitat par excellente
un environnement ouvert fréquemment
tondu
les entreprises d'herbicides le pissali
c'est un allié de choix parce que
évidemment on peut vendre des produits
contre les pissali qui ont une relative
efficacité mais c'est impossible de se
débarrasser du pissenlit à définitive
donc c'est un perpétuel recommencement
donc un agent de vente extraordinaire et
par ailleurs lorsqu'on met un pesticide
contre un pissenlit on libère une niche
écologique on crée un trou dans la
pelouse et quoi de mieux qu'un autre
pissenlit de non seulement de pissali
pour se réinstaller dans cette niche
écologique laissez libre
[Musique]
il y a un mouvement qui est origine du
Royaume-Uni qui s'appelle en anglais
nobomé ou ici des filles pissenlit au
défi sans tondeuse et l'objectif c'est
de ne pas tendre la pelouse pendant le
mois de mai essentiellement pour
permettre aux fleurs et particulièrement
le pissenlit qui est la principale
espèce qui va fleurir au mois de mai
dans les pelouses d'arriver à maturité
ça faisait de produire ces fleurs là qui
vont alimenter les insectes
pollinisateurs
il y a très peu d'études qui ont fait le
bilan mais il y en a une où est-ce qu'on
sait qui montre qu'effectivement une
pelouse qui n'est pas tondu en main va
avoir 30% de plus de fleurs en abondance
et en diversité trois fois plus
d'insectes à diversité et 5 fois plus
des sacs pollinisateurs en abondance
donc cela a un effet ça peut contribuer
à un environnement un écosystème urbain
beaucoup plus simple en définitive
[Musique]